relationships suffer from a fundamental
tension between the desire to be honest
and the fear of being abandoned we go
into relationships in order to be
ourselves but were we to be really
entirely ourselves there is a high risk
we would be left
silence seems the price we so often have
to pay for companionship
however much we may claim to be
open-minded very few of us genuinely
make room for another person's
complexity insofar as we are its targets
we say they can tell us anything but in
practice the topics any of us are really
prepared to listen to is small and
lovers unconsciously mutually know it
tell me who you really are just leave
out most of the details
how quickly most relationships would end
if one were to say I love you but
sometimes I'd like to have an affair or
sometimes I catch you from a certain
angle and I despise you or sometimes for
a while I wish you weren't in my life or
sometimes you bore me or your flaws have
been driving me to despair
and yet while saying something like this
puts a relationship at risk saying
nothing is not unproblematic either we
can't go through love being simply
polite our entire emotional system goes
numb when we have to keep a lid on a
gigantic lie emotions that haven't been
expressed tend to end up simply being
acted out
it seems we can't easily either say
nothing or something
it would help hugely if Society were to
give us a better picture of Love That
prepared us at a collective level way
before this or that lover was in
question for the legitimacy of
ambivalent feelings including anger
disappointment and disloyalty and
reassured us that we didn't need to
panic at such feelings occasional
emergence that they were likely to pass
and would generally just a sign of two
people getting very close
the greatest favor we can pay our lovers
is to allow them so long as there is
never contempt or violence in the mix to
hate us a lot sometimes
the people who are the experts at this
are parents of three-year-olds when a
small child says mommy or daddy I hate
you a lot today parents do what we
should all generally do they manage not
to take it personally
they understand instinctively that love
is very complicated they don't hold
honesty against a person whom they know
is fundamentally good and kind they know
the mood will alter and most importantly
they remember how often they have felt
exactly the same